par alex carignan bonsoir docteur
carignan bonsoir ses rouages faisons un
plaisir de vous retrouver oui et c'est
ça vous étonne pas comme un nom ce qu'on
demande à toutes les personnes âgées
dans les résidences dans les milieux de
vie comme on dit de se faire vacciner
pour une troisième fois
mais je pense sébastien a très bien
résumé les points importants d'ailleurs
on voit depuis quelques semaines une
augmentation les jeunes à l'école ce
n'est pas catastrophique mais on voit
quelques cas quelques éclosion dans les
ch et celle des les résidences pour
personnes âgées et on a aussi maintenant
des données qui nous montrent
l'efficacité en fait parce qu'on sait
qu'après cinq ou six mois il ya une
baisse graduelle de l'efficacité chez
les populations âgées vulnérables et on
sait maintenant qu'une troisième dose
bien rétablir en fait cette efficacité
l'a donc si on veut éviter les éclosions
éviter évidemment des situations
catastrophiques comme au printemps 2000
verges pense pas qu'on retournerait
l'oeuvre de même mais parce que c'est
une bonne décision expliquez-moi
pourquoi on dit par ailleurs aux gens de
85 88 90 qui vivent à la maison encore
il y en a quand même pas mal que eux
n'ont pas besoin de cette troisième dose
bien évidemment il ya la notion de
contact est beaucoup moins de contacts
dans une résidence pour personnes âgées
on a davantage de contacts avec d'autres
personnes un risque d'infection qui est
plus élevé par ailleurs il ya un suivi
en temps réel au niveau du ministère et
les spéculoos suivi en temps réel de
l'efficacité de la vaccination dans la
communauté mais pour l'instant à fait
qu'on ne voit pas de baisse d'efficacité
de la vaccination même temps des
populations plus âgées
est ce assez suivie en paraissait
possible que des ajustements ans la
science évolue les données
l'épidémiologie vaut lui qu'on doit
s'adapter mais pour le moment je suis à
fait confortable avec le fisc on se
concentre sur les personnes en sièges
celle d un rpa c'est aussi ce qui est
recommandé d'ailleurs que leur accord à
la sen qui est sorti aujourd'hui au
niveau canadien parce qu'on a vu le
président baden qui a eu sa dose de
rappel hier il a mené les caméras on le
voit aux états unis on y voit plus large
mal ah
oui effectivement c'est basé sur le fel
l'étude entre autres une étude
israélienne que montrer qu on rétablit
enfin une paix avec une dose de rappel
ça s'adressait à des gens de plus de 65
ans donc aux etats-unis de dix sites il
ya les plus largement faut dire que aux
etats-unis la situation est fort
différente les taux de vaccination sont
beaucoup plus faibles que le virus
circule plus largement on était un
intervalle plus courant chez nous on ne
tue un intervalle de dos plus l'on en
fait pour la majorité de la population
est là il ya de plus en plus de données
on voit d'ailleurs à présenter sous peu
qui nous montrent l'efficacité d'un
intervalle plus longs ni efficacité plus
important par rapport à intervalles plus
courts donc et des situations je passe
différentes les coûts d'énergie
différente au québec
quand on est sûrs d'être moins pressés
d'aller vers eux deux une troisième
doses pour une population plus large
est-ce que docteur carignan ça ne
présage pas par ailleurs d'une
vaccination qui votent pour les gens
milieu de vie pour les personnes âgées
l'action qu'il ya des deux plus proches
que ça va être une vaccination quasiment
aussi moelleux ou quoi
pas nécessairement aux six mois on va
voir c'est toujours libres selon
l'évolution mais effectivement est ce qu
on pourrait avoir des dozos de rattle
incertaine intervalles là on fait on est
quand même au début de la vaccination
donc long on doit s'adapter à la
situation actuelle
bon lorsqu'on aura atteint une des plus
larges dans la population on va voir le
niveau de circulation du virus à ce
moment là pour se réadapter mais ce sont
de bonnes questions
malheureusement on n'a pas les réponses
pour l'instant et peut-être que les gens
moins âgés en bonne santé il y aura une
dose de rappel dans six mois huit mois
un an le ceppol
c'est à suivre comme je le mentionnais
comme toi l'intervalle plus long est ce
que vous ne protégez plus longtemps
c'est une possibilité
mais c'est à suivre mais certainement
dans la population en bonne santé plus
jeunes dirais qu'il ya eu dans ce
contexte il ya pas de très bons
l'autocar et quand on offre aux
personnes âgées en même temps le vaccin
pour l'influenza pour la grippe que
c'est une bonne idée est-ce qu'il n'y a
pas des gens qui vont dire bon ben ça
suffit pas passer ma vie à me faire
vacciner ou vous dites aux personnes
âgées
oui il n'y a pas de contre-indication de
recevoir la grippe et la commune
non il n'y a pas de préoccupation par
exemple d'interaction entre les
différentes les vaccins coville d
influenza il ya quand même plusieurs
autorités qui ont statué à ce niveau là
je comprend qu'actuellement c'est ça
peut être beaucoup ça peut paraître
beaucoup pour déjà qu'ils n'aiment pas
les injections par contre on a des
vaccins en trouve pour le vaccin contre
la copie d'un vaccin qui est efficace il
ya des motrices ou sa sécurité
chez ces groupes d'âge là haut niveau de
l'influenza malheureusement c'est aussi
une source de préoccupation bord de
longue date dans les soins longue durée
on a aussi fait face à plusieurs
éclosions donc je pense que c'est
justifié actuellement on veut aussi
profiter du timing en fait de la
campagne de vaccination en ligue 2 je
pense que c'est un bon moment pour
atteindre les gens c'est ce site est
pour
très bien toujours claire d'autres cas
rien je vais prendre quelques secondes
du pont long j'ai lu en fin de semaine
ce que c'était sur notre site je crois
que oui que les réseaux sociaux les
commentaires hargneux oublier les
commentaires nous nous vous avez loigné
où vous tendait à vous éloigner de la
sphère publique moi je vais vous
rappeler combien vous avez été utile
pour nous téléspectateurs j'ai reçu des
centaines et des centaines de courriels
vous remercier pour vos éclaircissements
vous remerciant aussi de dire ça je le
sais pas la science est pas arrivé là
alors je voulais vous encourager façon
vous fait moins souvent puis
heureusement ça faisait que ça va mieux
mais ne vous en faites pas pas de
réseaux sociaux on trouve du bien mais
beaucoup de n'importe quoi sur les
réseaux sociaux ou sites web et j'ai
appris vous avez certainement une plus
grande expérience que moi là dedans
effectivement à demeurer plus
imperméable face à ces ce type de
commentaire là lors de l'été 2020
j'avais prennent quand je vous dirais
essentiellement liée à sa bombe l'on
reprenne je pense qu'il ya un besoin
toujours de contrer la désinformation
c'est pour ça qu'on est toujours présent
donc
on poursuit le travail on se fait une
carapace peu un peu effectivement on
prend le bon et le moins bon on laisse
passe très bien je voulais je tenais à
vous le dire personnellement merci c'est
gentil merci merci de tenir la prochaine
au revoir